ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BELL BARGES BRADFORD CABALLERO
CHIANG DALLY DODD THEY'RE ALSO
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ GROWS
HERTZBERG HILL WEST WHERE.
JACKSON JONES LEYVA FIRE
MITCHELL MONNING MORE LUCK
MORRELL NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO
ROB. RUBIO SKINNER STERN.
NUMBER WHY CAL SKI WIENER WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE ROLE AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LEAD IN PRAYER TODAY BUT THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN
SYSTEM CHAU CORPSMAN AFTER
WHICHWILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR. SKINNER.
LET US BE CENTERED IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. AS WE CELEBRATE BLACK
HISTORY MONTH LET US PRAY IN
THE WORDS OF MARIAN WRIGHT
EDELMAN AN ADVOCATE FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS. LORD I
CANNOT PREACH LIKE MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR. OR TURN A
POETIC PHRASE LIKE MAYA ANGELOU.
BUT I CARE AND I'M WILLING TO
SERVE. I DO NOT HAVE FRED
SHUTTLESWORTH AND HARRIET
TUBMAN'S COURAGE. BUT I CARE
AND WILLING TO SERVE. I CANNOT
SAYING LIKE FANNIE LOU HAMER OR
OR ORGANIZE LIKE ELLA BAKER AND
BAYARD RUSTIN. BUT I CARE AND
I'M WILLING TO SERVE. I AM NOT
WHOLLY LACK ARCHBISHOP TUTU. OR
FOR GIVING LACK MANDELA BUT I
DO CARE AND I'M WILLING TO
SERVE. I AM NOT BRILLIANT LIKE
DOCTOR TO BOYS. OR IS ELOQUENT
AS SOJOURNER TRUTH AND BOOKER
T. WASHINGTON. BUT I CARE AND
WILLING TO SERVE. USE ME AS YOU
WILL TODAY AND TOMORROW TO
BUILD A NATION AND A WORLD
WHERE NO ONE IS LEFT BEHIND AND
WHERE EVERYONE FEELS WELCOME A
MAN. COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE. OUR
THIS IS. MISSION THIS IS A FULL
WITH US ALL. MEMBERS ARE GONNA
GET GOING ON FIRST UP IS
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. PORTS FROM CAN
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTIONS IN FIRST READINGS
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL. NINE FORTY FORTY
ONE FORTY TWO FORTY THREE FORTY
FOUR FORTY FIVE FORTY SIX FORTY
SEV
NINE FIFTY SEVEN. PART PART.
OUR TEAM WORK READ THANK YOU
MISTER SECRETARY I'M GOING TO
BRIEFLY MOVE BACK TO YOU.
MOTIONS WROTE RESOLUTIONS I'VE
JUST BEEN MADE AWARE OF THAT WE
HAVE. DICK CONES IN THE BACK
THE BROTHER IN LAW OF SENATOR
WHITE KASKI PLEASE GIVE HIM
SAID CALIFORNIA SENATE WELCOME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MOVIE BACK TO CONSIDERATION
DAILY FILE. WE HAVE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH THREE SENATOR WILL KEY
IS NOT HERE AT HIS DUST. OKAY
THANK YOU TIMES IN OUR WALK.
SENATOR WELCOME SECTOR. OKAY
FIRST FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF MATTHEW
DEVOE AND KIMBERLY PATILLO
BRONSON FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION. MR
NOVELS A DIRECTOR SYSTEMS
TRANSFORMATION AT THE AT THE
WEST AT CENTER FOR PREVENTION
AND EARLY INTERVENTION. AS A
FORMER SUPERINTENDENT OF SAYING
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. SB
TEAR BRONSON IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR POLICY STRATEGY
FIRST FIVE LA. THEY WERE
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JANUARY TWENTY SECOND ON
UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS HI
BATES I FELT HI ORIGINS HI
BRADFORD HI. HI CHIANG. THANK
YOU I DALY. OKAY HI DODD HI THE-
HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI ON
THE- I GROW. I HERTZBERG RIGHT
BY HILL HI HUESO WITH SO HIGH
TADO. HI JACK OR WHICH ARE
JONES HI BY LATE. I REQUIRE HI
MITCHELL HI MOM. FIVE MORE LOOK
I HI MORALE. NEIL I PAN. HI
POURTANT. HI RALPH BY ROOM. I
SKINNER. OUR STERN I NUMBER. HI
WHY CAL SKI. HI WIENER. I WILL.
HI SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUT
MEMBERS MORRELL. I ALL EYES
THIRTY NO NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT CONFIRM FOLLOWED
NUMBER TWO THANK YOU PRESIDENT
MAY ARE PRESENT FOLLOWED NUMBER
TWO WHICH IS A COPPER OF
HONORABLE HAVE BEEN A TO THE
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONTROL
APPEALS BOARD MISS MEDIA-
BENICIA. PREVIOUSLY SERVICE ARE
CALLING IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY
AND RECENTLY SERVED AS A
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR FOR THE
COUNCIL FOR A STRONG AMERICA
SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND WITH THE UNANIMOUS VOTE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT.
HERE NINETEEN ON THE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA. ATKINS HI BATES I
FELT HI GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI JANE. I BY THE
ALLEY I DON. HI THE RAW SO HI
GALGIANI HI GLAZER. I GONZALEZ.
HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI HILL.
HI WES. HI TODD. HI JACKSON HI
JONES. HI LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL HI MONNING. HI MORE
LOOK. HI MORALE. HI NAY. HI PAN
I PORTANTINO HI HI ROTH HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI STERN HI
I'M BURKE I WHY CAL SKI. HI
WIENER. HI WILK I BY MR POLICE
CALLED AFTER. ALLEN HI ARCHIE.
HI GROWTH HI. I JUST THIRTY
NINE ZERO THE POINT MINUTES
CONFIRM MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
THREE CENTER WILL THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
PERCENT FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
WHICH IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
DOCTOR TINA SLOAN TO THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING DR SLOAN IS THE
DIRECTOR LEAD PRINCIPAL
INVESTIGATOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHER EDUCATION RESEARCH AND
IMPROVING NETWORK AND CURRENTLY
SERVES AS THE COMMISSION'S
CHAIR SHE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JANUARY
TWENTY SECOND WITH THE
UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT. EARN SEEN NONE
MISS SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHIE. HI
ATKINS I BATES I BEL HI FOR. HI
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I JANE I
DALLY I DODD HI THE ROSS. HI
GALGIANI HI GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ
HI GROW. HI HERTZBERG. HILL HI
WES SO HI. HI JACKSON. HI JONES
HI LEYVA. HI REQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI MONNING HI MORE
LOOK HI MORALE. HI NIELSEN HI
BEN HI PORTANTINO. HI RALPH HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI STERN HI
I'M BURKE HI WHY CAL SKI HI
WIENER. I WILL HI SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT HERTZBERG HI. I
THIRTY NINE KNOWS THE POINT
MINUTES CONFIRM NOW MOVING TO
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX. SEARCHING ARE YOU
PREPARED. THE SECTOR PLEASE
ROUTE SENATE RESOLUTION SEVENTY
ONE BY SENATOR CHIANG RELATIVE
TO AMERICAN HEART MONTH AND
WEAR RED DAY. CENTER DURING THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SOME OF US
ARE WEARING RED TODAY OR HAVE
RED PEN SAID KNOWLEDGE WEAR RED
DAY ON THE FIRST FRIDAY OF
EVERY FEBRUARY THE NATION COME
TOGETHER. TO CREATE A GROUND
SWELL OF RED FROM COAST TO
COAST IN AN EFFORT TO REMIND
AMERICANS FOCUS ON THEIR HEARTS
AND ENCOURAGE THEM GET THEIR
FAMILIES FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITIES INVOLVED IN HEART
DISEASE PREVENTION. AND TODAY
THE STATE CAPITAL IS GOING READ
TO TAKE PART IN THIS NATION
WIDE EVENT. AND WORK TOWARDS
ENDING HEART DISEASE AND STROKE
IN WOMEN ON BEHALF OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION TODAY.
THE RECORD. FEBRUARY'S AT RED
DAY CALIFORNIA. MEMBERS HARD
TO. IN ONE KEY. OF KILLING MORE
WOMEN THAN ALL FORMS OF CANCER
COMBINED. IT RECOGNIZES THE
ENTIRE MONTH OF FEBRUARY AS
AMERICAN HEART MONTH IN ORDER
TO RAISE AWARENESS OF THE
IMPORTANCE. OF THE ONGOING
FIGHT AGAINST HEART DISEASE AND
STROKE. THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE ABOUT 80% OF CARDIAC
EVENTS CAN BE PREVENTED THROUGH
EDUCATION LIFESTYLE CHANGES.
SUPPORT FOR THIS RESOLUTION
INCLUDES THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION THE AMERICAN STROKE
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS WELL
HARD DISEASES STRUGGLE AMONG
THE GENERAL POPULATION
FIREFIGHTERS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS CRITICAL EFFORT
TO TACKLE HEART DISEASE AND
STROKE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. INNER
JACKSON. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I WANT TO
JOIN IN THANK OUR COLLEAGUE-
AND THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS FOR THIS
YOU KNOW THE HEART DISEASE IS A
SECRET KILLER FOR WOMEN AND
IT'S A VERY INTERESTING THAT
THE SIGNS THAT OF THAT EXIST
FOR WOMEN WITH HEART DISEASE
VERY DIFFERENT THAN THE SIGNS
THAT EXIST FOR MEN AND FOR
DECADES WE BASICALLY IGNORED.
THOSE SIGNS AND DIDN'T TREAT
HEART DISEASE WITH WOMEN IN
GREAT MEASURE BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
DO THE RESEARCH AND THE REASON
WE DIDN'T DO THE RESEARCH IS
THAT WELL WOMEN'S BODIES ARE
TOO COMPLICATED AND SO IS
SOMEONE WHO COMES FROM A FAMILY
WHERE HEART DISEASE HAS A BEEN
A KILLER OF FOR BOTH THE MEN
AND WOMEN IN MY FAMILY I WANT
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT WE'RE
NOW ADDRESSING WHAT IS BEEN FOR
FAR TOO LONG A SECRET KILLER OF
WOMEN. WE KNOW THAT MEN HAVE
HEART ATTACKS AND HEART DSEASE
AND CERTAINLY WE DO OUR BEST TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES BUT
WOMEN ARE EQUALLY IS SEPARABLE
AND BY THIS READ PRESS DAY OR
FOR SOME TO FOR BLACKS. PLACER
IT'S A REMINDER ALL OF US TO
TAKE GOOD CARE OF A- AND WE
WHEN WE- SOME. THE LEAD US
WONDER AND WE ARE IN THE OF HOW.
THAT WE TAKE A ME ACTION
CONSULT WITH OUR PHYSICIANS AND
ASK THOSE REALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO. LIVE GOOD QUALITY
LIVES AND LIVE THEM LONGER AND
IN MORE HOUSE THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THINK SOONER JACKSON
CENTER PAN. THANK YOU I'M FOR
MEMBERS I RISE AND SPEAK OF THE
REPORT READ. AND ONE THING THE-
AUTHORS AN THE WOMEN'S RE THIS
FULL STRAY AND HEART ATTACKS OR
SOMETHING THAT THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF TIME. FOR PEOPLE TO
RESPOND TO THAT THAT THE
MINUTES THAT PASSED BY OUR
CRITICAL AND THAT'S WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HAVE BROAD PUBLIC
AWARENESS. BY TIME SOMEONE
REALIZES WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
THEM- OFTENTIMES. YEAH NOT
ENOUGH JUST TO LIKE WAITING
CALL THE DOCTOR SOMETHING NEED
TO BAIL RECOGNIZE AN AXE WESLEY
AND THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- I THINK IS
THIS RESOLUTION NOTES AND I
APPRECIATE MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
SANTA BARBARA POINTING IT OUT
IS THAT. OFTENTIMES WHAT WE
TELL PEOPLE ABOUT THE SYMPTOMS
ARE THE SYMPTOMS THAT APPEAR.
IN MEN. AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IS
THAT WHEN WOMENARE SUFFERING
SYMPTOMS THAT THEN MAY LEAD TO
A HEART ATTACK OR STROKE. THEY
ARE NOT AWARE OF THE PEOPLE
AROUND THEM ARE NOT AS AWARE SO
WE NEED TO RAISE THIS
AWARENESS- SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
RECOGNIZE WHAT'S HAPPENING AND
SO THEY CAN ACT IN TIME TO BE
SURE WE CAN MITIGATE. OUR
HALTS- THE INJURY OR DEATH THE
MAKER FROM THESE DISEASES SO
AGAIN- I THINK THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS OF THE THIS
RESOLUTION AND ORGANIZED. THANK
YOU. DARK SENATOR PAN ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. CENTER CHAIN WHICH
OUGHT TO CLOSE. JUST
RESPECTFULLY FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS ITEM IS OUT FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THE SITE. TURNING
SEEN NINE. OZ THIRD NINE KNOWS
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
A GERMAN IN MEMORIES THIS
AFTERNOON. FIRST UP IS SENATOR
CHIANG ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
YOUR JOURNEY MEMORY. SINGER
CHECK THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF THE LIFE
OF ESTHER WALLACE AND ANAHEIM
RESIDENT SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT WAS ALWAYS
IMPORTANT TO ESTHER WHO IS ONE
OF THE FOUNDERS OF THE WEST
ANAHEIM NEIGHBORHOOD
DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL AND SERVED
AS CHAIRWOMAN FOR TWENTY ONE
YEARS SHE ALSO SERVED AS
CHAIRWOMAN FOR THEIR WEST AND
I'M HOLIDAY TREE LIGHTING
PROGRAM AND THE ANAHEIM WESTERN
BARBECUE FOR SEVERAL YEARS. A
LONG TIME BOARD EMBER AND PAST
PRESIDENT OF AN AND BEAUTIFUL
ESTHER WAS ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE THELMA JORDON SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM PROVIDING ANAHEIM
STUDENTS WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RECEIVE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR COLLEGE HER TIRELESS
EFFORTS FOCUSED ON BETTERING
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR WEST
AND I'M RESIDENTS ESPECIALLY BY
AB ADVOCATING FOR BETTER SENIOR
HOUSING QUALITY AND BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND REDUCING
CRIME IMPOLITE IN WEST AND
HANG. WELL ESTHER'S WORK FOR
HER CITY WAS ADMIRABLE HER DEEP
LOVE FOR HER FAMILY AND THEIR
LOVE FOR HER WILL LIVE ON AS A
TRUE TESTAMENT TO HER LIFE
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
TURNING THE MEMORY WHAT S. S.
THANKS. DURING PLEASE EXTEND
THIS. FAMILY NAME. FOR MORE
ALIVE EXCEPT AS SENATOR
ARCHULETA YOU PREPARE. THANK
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS IS
WITH A PER SO THAT ARE TODAY TO
JR MEMORY OF LOS ANGELES CA
SHERIFF PROTECT AMBER LEASE.
AMBER LEASE ONE BORN IN SAN AND
MARCH TWENTY NINETEEN EIGHT THE
PARENTS DâN AND ELLEN. SHE
GRAY FROM LOS COUNTY SHERIFF'S.
AND BEGAN WORKING AT THE NORTH
COUNTY FACILITY. SHE COULD ROSE
TO THE IN LATE BECAME A
PATROLLED AND LANKY. EVENTUALLY
SHE EARN A POSITION THAT THE-
AND I TO THE WEST LAW SAN AND
HALL STAY. AND SERVE THEIR FOR
YEARS. ON TWELFTH WHILE OFF.
DETECTIVE NOTICE AN ELDERLY
WOMAN SH TO CROSS THE STREET.
NEARLY STOP HER VEHICLE AND
ASSIST THE WOMAN. WHO IS TO
CROSS AS SHE RETURNED HER CAR.
THE TECH LEAST WAS STRUCK BY A
AND STRUCK AND BY AN ONCOMING
VEHICLE. DETECTIVE LEASE WAS
INCREDIBLY AND TOUCHED EVERYONE
WHETHER POSITIVE AND UPLIFTING
PERSONALITY. DETECTIVE LEAST
WAS AN EX EXEMPLARY OFFICER AND
GREATLY MISSED BY HER STATION
AS WELL AS OUR COMMUNITY. SHE
LEAVE BEHIND A LEGACY OF
GENEROSITY AND SERVICE TO
ALTHOUGH SHE KNEW. SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER SON WALTER
DANIEL. HER PARENTS DANIELAND
ELLEN AND HER SISTERS HEATHER
SUNNY AND SAVANNAH. AND I WAS
THERE AT THE FUNERAL AND IF
YOU'VE EVER BEEN TO A FUNERAL
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT. I'VE BEEN
TO A FEW IN MY LIFETIME BUT
THIS WOULD TOUCH. BECAUSE THIS
WOMAN HAD TOUCHED SO MANY
PEOPLE AND SHE WENT DOWN TRY TO
HELP ONE ANOTHER. AND I TELL
YOU THAT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
MEN AND WOMEN IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE HAVE TO THINK OF
THEM AS BROTHERS SISTERS AUNTS
UNCLES AND EVEN GRANDMOTHERS
AND GRANDFATHERS. AND IT IS FOR
THESE REASONS THAT I ASKED TO
JOIN IN HER MEMORY THANK YOU.
THANK CENTER UNTIL IT WILL JUST
THIS CALIFORNIA SENATE
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY AND
PLEASE BRING THE NAME PORTS ARE
CAN BE PROPERLY MORE ALLIES.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU A MISTER PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES SIGH RICE TODAY
WITH. DEEP SADNESS TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF TED SHAW TED
PASSED AWAY ON FEBRUARY FIRST
AT SEVENTY FIVE FEBRUARY FIRST
WAS ALSO THE SAME DAY MY OWN
DAD PASSED AWAY- CORNELL HAMMER
CALIFORNIA JULY TWENTIETH.
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR TO PARENTS
JOHN AND JULIA SHAW TED
ATTENDED HOLY FAMILY CATHOLIC
CHURCH AND SO PASADENA AND
GRADUATED FROM ST FRANCIS HIGH
SCHOOL IN LOCKING OUT OF FLINT
RIDGE HE ALSO ATTENDED CITRUS
COLLEGE IN GLENDORA AND THEN
WENT ON TO THE UNIVERSITY OF-SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. HE MARRIED
JOAN MONSON ON AUGUST TWENTY
FOURTH NINETEEN SIXTY THREE-
TED SERVE THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA CITY COUNCIL AS MAYOR
FOR THREE TERMS FROM. NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY SIX UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP
HE AND A GROUP OF COMMUNITY
LEADERS BEGAN THE ICONIC FOURTH
OF JULY FESTIVAL IN SOUTH
PASADENA CALLED THE FESTIVAL OF
BALLOONS THAT FESTIVAL HAS
CELEBRATED FORTY YEARS AND IS
STILL GOING STRONG. HE WAS A
MAJOR SUPPORTER OF THE SOUTH
PASADENA TOURNAMENT OF ROSES
COMMITTEE WHICH BUILDS THE
OLDEST SELF BILL FLOAT IN THE
TOURNAMENT OF ROSES PARADE AND
IF YOU WATCH ALL OF THOSE
WONDERFUL FLOATS THE GO DOWN
COLORADO BOULEVARD. MY OF THEM
ARE BUILT PER. FLOAT BUILDING
COMM ALL BUT OF THEM ARE WHAT'S
CALLED SELF BUILT FOR THE
COMMUNITY THEMSELVES RAISES THE
MONEY HAS VOLUNTEERS AND SOUTH
PASADENA IS THE LONGEST SELF
BILL FLOAT. IN THE PARADE- AND
TED WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
CONTINUING TO FUND RAISE FOR
THAT AND DRIVE THE SOUTH
PASADENA TOURNAMENT OF ROSES
SOCIETY IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
AS HIS HEALTH- STARTED TO
DECLINE HE NEVER MISSED A BEAT
HE WAS ALWAYS AT EVERY EVENT.
CHAMPIONING THOSE EVENTS
RAISING MONEY GIVING IS
VOLUNTEER TIME WHETHER WAS THE
PANCAKE BREAKFAST ON FOURTH OF
JULY OR CRUISING FOR ROSES THE
ANTIQUE CAR SHOW HE WOULD HE
AND HIS WIFE ARE ALWAYS THERE
AND SO IT'S A HUGE VOID FOR THE
CITY OF PASADENA- HE WAS JUST A
NICE MAN WHO HELPED HIS
COMMUNITY BE SPECIAL. AND I ASK
YOU TO JOIN ME IN A TURNING IS
MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE WE EXTEND OUR
CONDOLENCES TO THE SHOP FAMILY
AND PLEASE BRING THE NAME FORTS
OR CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE.
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS I ASK
YOU TO. ADJOURN IN MEMORY JOIN
ME IN A JOURNEY IN MEMORY FOR
WHITNEY DOTSON. WHITNEY WAS A
PERSON THAT WAS VERY SPECIAL TO
ME BUT HE WAS ALSO VERY SPECIAL
TO. THE CITY OF RICHMOND IN
EAST BAY HE WAS A LIFELONG
ADVOCATE FOR THE PRESERVATION
AND PROTECTION. OF THE NORTH
RICHMOND SHORELINE. HE GREW UP
IN A PLACE CALLED PART CHESTER
VILLAGE PORCHESTER VILLAGE WAS
FOUNDED BY AFRICAN AMERICANS
WHO WERE BROUGHT TO. THE EAST
BAY TO WORK IN THE SHIPYARDS
AND THEY WERE OF COURSE
PREVENTED FROM OWNING HOMES. SO
IF YOU WERE TO SEE PORCHESTER
VILLAGE NOW IT IS RIGHT ON THE
SHORE LINE DEFINITELY- AT RISK
FOR SEA LEVEL RISE. IN
SOMEWHERE MOST PEOPLE PROBABLY
OTHER THAN LOVELY VIEWS WOULD
NEVER WANT TO LIVE BECAUSE IT'S
A MARSH. AND I YET THOSE
FAMILIES PARTLY UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF WHITNEY'S FATHER
THE REVEREND DOTSON. BUILT
HOMES AND CREATED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO OWN HOMES. AND
THE FAMILIES THAT LIVED THERE
ARE STILL FROM THOSE ORIGINAL
FAMILIES. AND GROWING UP IN
THAT MARSH AREA WHITNEY BECAME
A LIFELONG ENVIRONMENTALIST.
AND HE WHEN VARIOUS TIMES
EITHER TO PUT IN A SMALL
AIRPORT OR VARIOUS OTHER THINGS
HE AND HIS FAMILY AND THE
RESIDENTS OF PART CHESTER
VILLAGE WOULD ORGANIZE. AND
WORK TO PROTECT IT. I WAS
ELECTED TO THE EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT BOARD
THAT'S A INCREDIBLE I'M TO
COUNTY REGIONAL PARK AREA IN
THE EAST BAY. I AND I
REPRESENTED THE WHOLE RICHMOND
AREA PLUS OAKLAND BERKELEY AND
WHEN I. GOT ELECTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY THE POSITION BECAME
AVAILABLE AND WHITNEY RAN AND I
BACKED HIM 1100% TO HAVE A
LIFELONG RICHMOND RESIDENT
REPLACE ME ON THAT BOARD. TO
FIGHT FOR THE PRESERVATION OF
THAT AREA. AND SUBSEQUENTLY-
THE ONE OF THE PARKS IN THAT
AREA POINT PINOLE NOW HAS ITS
PRIMARY MARSH NAMED AFTER THE
DOTSON FAMILY. OUR WHITNEY
STARTED THE NORTH RICHMOND
SHORELINE FESTIVAL AND HE MADE
SURE THAT THE PARK DISTRICT
BROUGHT LOTS OF AMENITIES SO
RESIDENTS OF RICHMOND WOULD USE
IT. BECAUSE THERE'S OFTEN A BIG
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THOSE AREAS
THAT WE SET ASIDE AS PARKS IN
THE IN THE PEOPLE WHO COULD
HAVE BEST ACCESS TO THEM WE
DON'T ALWAYS CREATE THE- THE
TRAILS OR THE WE DON'T CREATE
THE KIND OF AMENITIES. THAT
WOULD MAKE THEM FEEL WELCOME
AND THAT'S WHAT WHITNEY STOOD
FOR ANY FOUGHT FOR IT HARD AND
HE SUCCEEDED HE PASSED AWAY
UNFORTUNATELY IN EARLY JANUARY
AT THE YOUNG AGE OF SEVENTY
FIVE. BUT HE WILL BE TRULY
MISSED BY ALL OF US AND I
DIDN'T TELL YOU ABOUT HIS
WONDERFUL BACKGROUND. HI IN
HEALTH COMMUNITY HEALTH
SERVICES HIS WORK OR THE STATE
OR VARIOUS OTHER THINGS BUT ALL
LEAVE IT THAT HE WAS A
FANTASTIC PERSON. AND THE EAST
BAY RICHMOND THE REGIONAL PARKS
HIS FAMILY HIS SISTER RE LS
START TO NEWMAN AND HIS SONS
ARE DAY RJ J. LONNIE AND- LOOK
MEN WILL GREATLY MISS MASS WILL
LIE THANK YOU. THANKS SKINNER
AND ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA SENATE
EXTEND OUR DO AND- TO DOT
FAMILY AND BRING. THE FORT SO
CAN BE MOM. MEMBERS I'M JUST
GONNA MOVE BACK FOR TO
PRIVILEGE THE FLOOR. INTO THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO. THE CALL IS A
ONE ON BLOCK WOMEN WHO ARE HERE
CAPITA DAY EUROPE IN A GALA
PLEASE STAY AND RECOGNIZED AND
THE YOUNG MEN TEASE WHO ARE
WITH THEM AS WELL. THE TWO MEN
TO USE. MEANT TO DO NOW WANT TO
STAND. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENCE HERE TODAY. WE BACK TO
MOTION WROTE LUCIEN TO
CONCLUDED. MEMBERS OF THERE'S
NO FOR BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE JUSTICE COLOR. WELL THANK
YOU MISTER AND- I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A POOR WE AND WE
WILL RECONVENE TOGETHER ON
FRIDAY FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH IN
WHICH YOU CAN ALL WEAR RED
AGAIN. AND MAYBE I WILL JOIN
YOU ON FRIDAY AND WEAR RED-
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH AT NINE AM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
pGERMAN MOTION WILL BE MADE WILL
RECONVENE FRIDAY AT NINE AM.